what is up everybody it's 414 anime here
for anime operon and today we're going
to be ranking not only every hashura but
also every demon Moon from weakest to
strongest this is gonna be absolutely
insane and in this video you're gonna
see where we place all these big guns
and you'll see who would be able to take
out who and most importantly who is the
strongest amongst them all now if you do
enjoy these Demon Slayer videos on the
channel and you'd like to see more make
sure to smash that like button if you
haven't already make this a video that
you subscribe and hit that notification
Bell to turn on all notifications you
can also follow us on Twitter and
Instagram at anime uproar we just want
to say a big thank you to Jason a fan of
the channel for requesting this video if
you have any future video requests make
sure to let us know in the comment
section below and now without further
Ado let's jump into It spoilers and all
kicking off the list and ranked dead
last quite literally is of course course
the former lower six Kyo guy who was
also known as the drum demon this guy
was the first proper Big Boy demon that
Tundra had to face and he was certainly
no joke at the time using the drums on
his body kyogai can control the drum
Mansion he can utilize the drums on his
body to teleport himself into different
rooms as well as to cause the house to
spin left right up and down kyogai also
had his claw strike when he struck the
drum on his chest now the faster he
drummed the quicker the rotations and
the amount of slashes that emerged all
in all kyogai was a very impressive
demon and worthy of the Moon title
however he lost that title after
reaching his limit and muzon simply
discarded him I think it's fair to say
that you know he isn't beating anyone
else on this list
next up we've got the lower six Moon
demon Kaman nue who held the position
after kyogai was demoted very little is
known about this guy and his powers so
it's hard to place him any higher than
this on the list but we can determine
that he was stronger than Kyo guy as he
was the demon to take over the rank of
lower six after kyogai had been demoted
moving on to lower Moon 5 rui rui was a
very interesting character with his
spider-like traits and was definitely
one who commanded fear a demon that you
definitely had to face with caution with
his blood demon art rui was able to make
fine web-like threads from his own flesh
that was like string and he could
control them as he liked you could say
that he was like a puppeteer as he
stretched the threads from his
fingertips Ruby's threads were extremely
strong and razor sharp that could even
cut nitrine's swords and deflect blows
from them as well to top it all off rui
can inject his blood through them giving
them a blood crimson color Aesthetics
aside this increases their toughness and
durability even further of course a very
mean demon to face this one but I don't
think he's going any higher on the list
now it would be very interesting to see
how quick a fight it would have been if
Tundra got a rematch against him now but
rui definitely played his part in
tanjaro's Journey so credit where it's
due then we've got cargo who was the
lower Moon 4. very interesting looking
demon I did like her design with the two
horns and whatnot now a lot of the lower
Moon demons we didn't really get a lot
of chance to check out and were
ultimately all wrecked by muzan so we
can only go off of what we know when
ranking them being lower Moon 4 we can
assume that she was stronger than ruin
power so she ranks higher though she was
the most cowardly admitting that she
would run if a hushra were to show up so
you could argue that she could be lower
on the list but in terms of strength we
will whack her here
following is lower Moon 3 wakaraba again
was a part of the group of the lower
moons that were leveled by muzon so we
didn't get to see any of his powers we
did get to see some of his speed as he
ran from muzon and though it was nowhere
near fast enough to escape the Demon
King it was impressive and I guess you
could say expected of a lower Moon
definitely ranking nowhere higher on the
list and is placed based on his lower
Moon ranking
much like lower Moon 2 rokoro again it's
the same situation in which we never got
to see any of his demon powers but based
on his rank it would be naive to say
that he wasn't strong of course nothing
compared to some of the beasts that we
have on this list but still lower Rank 2
is nothing to laugh about as many would
have fallen at his hands
next up is the former lower Rank 2 Hiro
and this guy is pretty cool the lower
moon is actually from the rengoku Side
Story and if you haven't checked it out
I strongly recommend it it's a very very
good read now Hiro utilized rifles
machine guns and even timed bombs when
in combat his demon powers are all about
creating and manipulating the Shadows So
within the Shadows he can store his
weapons and then pull them out as and
when needed Hiro could also use these
shadow wolves that were able to absorb
any weapons that were used against them
his blood demon art was tied into the
Wolf theme as he himself transformed
into this huge giant shadow wolf-like
creature that wielded a sword the
Shadows are definitely a very nasty
concept to come up against in a fight
and Jairo himself was pretty ruthless
but still he did end up losing to
rengoku pre him becoming a harsher of
course but we know that rangoku's built
different so a lower Moon shouldn't be a
problem for him as was the case in their
fight
final lower moon on the list is none
other than lower Moon one and moon and
yes not a single harsh Ray gab I
honestly don't think any of the hushra
would have a problem with a lower Moon
strong as they are I I just don't see
any of these demons taking down a
harshera personally so enmu was
definitely a very interesting demon and
one who was very deserving of the lower
Moon one rank not quite an upper moon
but definitely stood out amongst those
below him both his strength and mindset
were deserving of the status so his
blood demon art let him infiltrate a
person's dream and destroy their minds
by taking out their spiritual core to do
this he would need the person to
obviously be asleep and luckily for enmu
he also had the power to make this
happen enmu's flesh manipulation was
also very impressive as he was able to
fuse his body with huge objects such as
the the train as which we saw in that
Arc he can also sever his head and hands
from his body that can still move and
communicate he's even used his Talking
Hands to put people to sleep in this way
very very impressive set of powers and a
super tricky demon to come up against
but like I said that there's just no no
way no way a lower moon is taking out a
hosurer speaking of hashra the first
harshera on the list and it's the former
thunderhush for a jigarone of course
Thunder Sensei to zenitsu and kaigaku in
his day jigaro was a beast man like he
was known to be an extremely skilled and
Powerful swordsman as we know he was
skilled in thunder-breathing during his
time as a hushra he fought against
several strong demons however his time
as a hushra was cut sure as he chose to
give up his role as a pillar after
losing a leg in combat now there's no
denying that chigarro was an extremely
strong dude back in his day but I feel
that a lot of the former hashura are
behind the current generation the
current gen of hashura are just on a
different level and with all their
current forms and abilities I think that
a lot of the former hushra just wouldn't
be able to keep up with them jigaro
however is definitely not a weak man but
I can't see him taking down one of the
current upper moons
another former harsher up next in the
legendary water breathing Sensei
orokadaki orokadaki is another form of
hashra that we can certainly not throw
away and call him weak he's far from
that and was once one of the Demon
Slayer called strongest members being
the former water harshera however again
I think he doesn't stand up against the
current generation of harsheron in his
day he was a very powerful and skilled
swordsman he managed to capture and
imprison the hand demon we saw back at
final selection though nothing too much
to brag about now however at the time
that was still incredibly impressive our
boy has taught at least 14 people the
art of water breathing making him a very
knowledgeable and skilled teacher one of
which being of course kiyutomioka the
current water Harsh Realm this should
demonstrate how extensive and
magnificent aroka Ducky's Legacy is he
was able to make Tundra an effective
user of water breathing despite it not
being his natural technique as
impressive a teacher as he is I still
believe he would fall and the hands of
an upper Moon demon
okay first best girl on the list as well
as the first of the new generation of
hushra in the insect pillar shinobu
shinobu is a skilled Demon Slayer and
deserving of the title of insect
harshera she is however the weakest
hushra when it comes to Raw strength
unfortunately for our girl shinobu does
like the physical strength cut off a
demon's head like an average Demon
Slayer can however snowbu more than
makes up for her lack of physical Power
by using her cunning creativity and
other physical skills our girl is a
force to be reckoned with and that is
all thanks to her quick intelligence and
her skill with poisons in combat shinobu
decides to utilize a custom Katana that
functions as a stinger to inject deadly
wisteria-based poison that is extremely
harmful to Demons she covers this with
her own insect breathing style which was
designed to compensate for her flaws and
play on her strengths when it came to
taking down demons and even though
shinobu lacks brute strength she is
nevertheless are force to be reckoned
with because of her other abilities we
have somehow easily take out lower level
demons and of course go Toe to Toe with
upper Moon tune Doma for a short while I
personally love shinobu and I have so
much time for her and her style of
combat however I think shinobu's lack of
physical strength holder back in
comparison to the others on this list
where of course we're looking at them in
terms of their powers
moving on to Upper Moon 4 nakame nakame
was an interesting one to look at as her
powers aren't very deadly themselves but
just as shinobu I think it's a case of
how she uses these powers to compensate
that's where she really shines despite
having a little combat experience nakame
is an extremely deadly demon her Blood
Demon R is an extra dimensional area
that is basically a massive Fortress
nakame has complete control over it and
she can change the environment by merely
strumming her biwa now within the
Fortress there are numerous rooms with
an almost infinite variety throughout
the stronghold and she can
instantaneously transfer herself
anywhere and reconfigure the infinity
Castle entirely by strumming the B1 not
only that she can also teleport others
to wherever she wants making it near
impossible to attack her on top of that
she can also create detached eyeballs
from her own body and use them to spy on
others from long range definitely a very
tricky customer to come up against but
in a battle of strength this is where
she will fall easily in my opinion for
nakami is all about using the Fortress
to elude enemies to send demon Slayers
to somewhere or you know someone else to
be defeated or to provide support to the
other demons fighting inside the
infinity Castle I feel if she was caught
then she would fall to the others on
this list
another former hashara and the late
sister of shinobus next up we have the
flower hashura Kane as a former hushra
she is one that we don't have a lot of
information on when it comes to her
powers we know that she wielded a normal
Katana in contrast to her sister
shinobu's modified one which gives us an
indication that she did possess the
physical strength to chop off a demon's
head now it's important to remember that
in becoming a harshera one must have
killed one of the 12 kizaki or killed at
least 50 demons so it's safe to say that
Kane was easily a powerful Demon Slayer
herself who was skilled and possessed
natural Talent we also know that Kane
was always held in high regards by her
peers and that's saying something as I
feel other hashra can and will be
brutally honest when it comes to
assessing another's strength and
capabilities when it of course comes to
facing demons and it's a real shame we
never got to find out more about Kane we
know that with her flower breathing she
was able to battle against upper moon to
Doma until sunrise and though she was
ultimately defeated and killed by Doma
facing off against him for so long is a
true Testament to her strengths and
skills but because we don't know any
more about her in terms of her power I
feel that we can't place her any higher
up than this
next up is upper Moon 6 kaigaku kaigaku
and zenitsu were both students of the
former thunderhashra jigaro koishima
they were both selected to be giguro's
heirs which infuriated kaigaku since he
desired to get all of the credit now
kaigaku could use all of the Thunder
breathing techniques except for the
first form now since he was never made a
harsh rakai Goku sought out becoming a
demon in order to increase his own power
and despite his inexperience when it
came to his own blood demon art muzon
still saw how powerful a demon kaigaku
already was and gifted him with the
vacant position of upper Moon 6 which
was of course left by guitero and
kagaku himself is a very lethal demon
with his swordsmanship abilities and his
proficiency as a Demon Slayer this
combination is extremely deadly as
kaigaku's power was a mixture of both a
Demon Slayer and a demon at this point
his Blood Demon are also skyrocketed his
Thunder breathing Tech techniques he had
Prides becoming a demon into
electrokinesis not only were they way
more powerful but the lightning was also
a really sick black color that was
generated from his own flesh and blood
now to add to his power kaigaku had also
mastered total concentration breathing
which is way more immune to the effects
of muzan's blood so in order for him to
be transformed into a demon it required
a lot more of the Demon King's blood
which obviously equals more power the
more muzon's blood you obtain the
stronger the demon you become and on top
of that zenitsu had said that kaigaku
consumed a large number of people in the
short time that he had become a demon
only making him much much stronger
kaigaku's downfall however was his lack
of experience with his new demon powers
he had only been a demon for a short
period of time thus he hadn't been able
to reach anywhere near his full
potential yushiro commented that due to
kaigaku's short time as an upper ranked
demon the majority of his powers and
abilities were yet to have been mastered
and that if he had faced off against
zenitsu just a year later he would have
killed him instantly now it's due to
that inexperience that kaigaku feels
short hair for me but I imagine he would
have been an upper Moon Four at least
given time I don't think he becomes
stronger than a Kaza but I definitely
think he becomes stronger than the upper
moons above him at this time and
definitely more than a handful for any
of the harshera
the last former harshera on the list
goes to Big Daddy rangoku shinjuru who
was the former flame harsheron of course
we don't know an awful lot about
shinjiro being a former harsher and all
but we know that he was extremely
powerful and equally as skilled when it
came to his swordsmanship and Flame
breathing I rank him higher on this list
because the guy comes across to me as a
complete tank an absolute unit that I
feel would have been able to dispatch
the upper moons we have had on the list
so far I just feel like before the
passing of his wife he was easily a
well-respected and Powerful Demon Slayer
who wielded the strength to go
toe-to-toe with even the strongest of
demons do I think he beats all of them
no certainly not hence his place here
but I feel like when compared to the or
the former hushra on the list he is the
strongest of the bunch however I think
he does fall short compared to the new
generations of Slayers minus our poor
best girl shinobu of course but yeah I
would have
send this guy in a fight man I bet he
was a total beast when it came to his
own flame breathing techniques
next up we have the flashy sound hashra
who has more wives than I do cups of
coffee which believe me is a lot here we
have none other than tengen uzui now
trust me when I say that tengen is an
absolute unit not only is he a very
powerful and skilled fighter but he is
also the second most physically strong
hashra as well as the fastest runner of
the bunch definitely a dude who deserves
all credit and respect where it's due
however despite those impressive Feats
he does lack against the other harshera
when it comes to the complete package
though I will say that tengen is a very
good indicator of just how strong the
hushra are if he is technically ranked
eighth out of the new generations nine
now one of tengen's core strengths is
when he utilizes his very own unique
ability called musical score musical
score is a technique that can get
invented utilizing his enhanced hearing
to operate in combination with his sound
breathing here tangent is his opponents
fighting Maneuvers and breaks down their
strikes into sound allowing him to read
them like sheet music to the point that
each battle resembles a song to him
tengen has an advantage over his enemies
as a result of being able to comprehend
their every move and blind spots however
its downside is that it takes tengen a
while to finish the score now this
ability combined with his sound
breathing his Shinobi style his epic
naturing Cleavers and the anti-demon
bombs it just makes tengen a very unique
and exceptional fighter tengen of course
has the reputation of being one of the
weakest hushura however considering how
powerful all the hoshra are now that's
hardly a bad thing he is still immensely
strong and can compete with any demon
however I think it's a shame that he
retired before receiving a power
increase that would have allowed him to
improve his skills further that of
course being the manifestation of the
Demon Slayer Mark as we saw it took the
help of tanjaro zenitsu and nosuke
nezuko and his wives to take down
kyotaro and Doki however I strongly
believe that if tengen had gained the
Demon Slayer Mark he would have not only
been strong enough to solo kyotaro and
Doki but also upper 5 Kyoko as well
however of course he didn't and he
retired to live with his three beautiful
wives and I'm totally not jealous about
it or anything but if you wanted to
choose those three smoking hot babes
over becoming much stronger than that's
your own decision bro but you walked
away from being something much bigger
than what you were and who am I kidding
man I would have made the same choice
and a long time ago be happy with your
wives my boy be happy
so moving on to the brother and sister
double act we have upper Moon six ducky
and kyotaro guitero and ducky were
formed as one demon for a long time
sharing the upper rank 6 title and I've
got to say things got real serious when
these two first appeared in the story
and they were certainly no joke at all
now because kyotaro and Doki were so
formidable an opponent this made us all
wonder how powerful the other upper
ranks were and of course in order to
defeat them the core group of our three
Lads nezuko tengen and his wives they
all had to work together as well as pray
that a bit of luck was on their side
there is no question that kuturo was the
strong of the two siblings but doki's
powers and abilities were certainly not
to be taken lightly doki's blood demon
art is Obi sash manipulation these OB
sashes are created from her flesh and as
a result they are both powerful and
precise enough to take down her enemies
just like an octopus utilizes its
tentacles she can dispatch these sashes
in the same way she can even transform
pieces of her own body into these sashes
for instance if someone were to attempt
to sever her neck she could transform it
into this fabric which would then Flex
with the sword and be more difficult to
sever she can also retain living humans
in her sashes which she does to preserve
the quality of her meals she is even
capable of separating a portion of
herself allowing the sash to work
independently and keep watch over things
like her stockpiles of alive victims
real nasty stuff as for cutero's
power-up his demon abilities amplify his
already existing sick sickle skills say
that three times really fast he can make
poison coated sickles out of his own
flesh and blood as well as that gutero
had the ability to launch numerous blood
swords at his enemies now in addition to
his blood demon art he had the ability
to manipulate his sister's body to
conduct flawlessly timed tag team
assaults the fact that both his head and
his sister's head had to be severed at
the same time to prevent them from just
regenerating is an additional advantage
of the power the tag team siblings had
now muzon said that docu always held
kyotaro back in that he could have
become so much more without her I can
definitely see this as being true and I
imagine without her he would have been
at least stronger than upper moon five
but I don't think he would have Rose any
higher than that if you ask me
speaking of upper Moon 5 it's everyone's
favorite Fishman gyoko actually I doubt
he's anyone's favorite but if he is then
fair play I'll admit the guy was
certainly entertaining
but you know Gotta Give it to gyoko
though man I don't think he's fight with
muichiro gave him much credit especially
after murichiro like attained the Demon
Slayer Mark but that does go to show
just how much of a difference
manifesting the mock makes but if you
compare Doki and kyotaro's hush for a
death count of seven to gyoko's 15 then
that gives you a good indication of how
much power this demon had Kyoko of
course was this strange being with an
eyeball for a mouth and mouth for eyes
his look was one of the most unique in
the series to be fair and he possessed
some fairly impressive skills and his
attacks also had a pretty unique twist
to them he appeared to be preoccupied
with creativity frequently incorporating
those skills into battle which we see in
his porcelain vase blood demon art gioko
can teleport between his numerous pots
until the pots are destroyed he can also
release fish-like demons that feed on
enemy flash even if the opponent manages
to cut them they will discharge a deadly
liquid that is absorbed through their
skin Joko can also call octopus
tentacles from his jaw and also imprison
opponents in suspended water now when he
requires additional strength and power
he can switch into another more powerful
form he has scales that are tougher than
diamonds and everything he touches
changes into fishes which is uh all
sorts of gross right in this ultimate
form gyoko refers to himself as an
existence without boundaries and he
tends to refer to himself and his power
like that of a Gods only to be
completely wrecked verbally and
physically by the young muichiro of
course but yeah like I said I don't
think Yoko gets the credit he deserves
because of that fight his harsher
account is very impressive and though
I've said that the current generation of
harshera are on a different level now
ahoshira is still a hushra and shouldn't
be taken lightly saying that Yoko
definitely doesn't move up any higher on
this lists though I'll admit the guy
does have my respect
next up is the bestest of best girls and
actually my favorite character in Demon
Slayer the love harsh remitri and no not
for the reasons I can hear you judging
me for right now her character all round
is awesome and I love her like her
powers are sick her personality is
contagious AF and her part in the
overall story is really really cool and
well yeah yeah she's she's best girl as
well she is attractive but
yeah just let me like her okay truth be
told I actually tried to sneak her near
the top of this list due to my obvious
bias for her but gozen and Anime they
completely caught me out yeah total wow
moment but make sure to definitely drop
a like on this video for my effort on
that front at least
now the love harshera doesn't appear to
be a fighter with a lot of raw strength
at first glance however misery actually
boasts one of the greatest raw strength
levels proving that appearances may be
quite deceiving this is because
mitsuri's muscles are eight times dense
than those of an average human due to a
unique muscular makeup giving her
superhuman strength although to keep
that up she has to eat a lot in fact
means Rick eats as much as three sumo
wrestlers in fact more so further Aid in
telling how strong an impressive mitsuri
is she completed final selection with
only six months of training a feat which
kyojiro Ren Goku found exceptional now
misery invented the breathing technique
known as love breathing after after
utilizing the experience of flame
breathing she picked up while serving as
the tsugoku of kyotro rangoku Love
breathing makes use of both meat series
unusual whip-like nitrine's sword and
her superhuman strength and flexibility
she can launch attacks with a broad
range of motion and extended ranges
using her breathing style something a
regular Katana would not be able to do
at all during her battle against
hontangu's clones of harkerton misery
awakened her Demon Slayer Mark which
gave her physical strength endurance
precision and power a dramatic boost
allowing her to stand on equal grounds
with the Clone who was equal to the
strength of four upper moons misery is
absolutely amazing and with the
Awakening of her Demon Slayer Mark she
skyrocketed in power but to defeat
huntengu that of course was a group
effort thus we can't place her higher on
the list I do believe however that she
would have been able to take down Kyoko
alone with her Demon Slayer Mark
manifested and that speaks volumes to
how impressive a fighter she is
speaking of upper moon for hontengu he
is up next on the list now at first
glance he definitely seemed an odd
choice for his place among the upper
moons but he definitely went on to
establish himself as one of the series
most fearsome foes it took the love
hushra meets Rick and roji with an
awakened Demon Slayer Mark tanjaro
nezuko and genya to defeat hontangu and
it was far from an easy task for them
hontengu is a really strange one he was
a total coward but it was his lack of
Courage that was the secret behind his
power the demon is quite cunning to be
firm he's difficult to see and strike
due to his tiny physique that he can
take on hontangu was very unique in the
way that he could separate his emotions
and those emotions took form in
manifested clones he creates an anger
clone that attacks using lightning a joy
clone with wind-based attacks a sorrow
clone with a spear a pressure clone that
fights using sound then there is a fear
clone with strong defensive capabilities
that contains hontangu's core and a
large resentment clone where which acts
as the last line of defense that
conceals the original demon in its heart
and if that wasn't enough the anger
clone could absorb the other emotion
clones to form the extremely powerful
hatred clone who was insanely strong not
only could he use all the powers of the
other clones but he can also summon a
huge wooden dragon with multiple heads
hontangu was really something else and
though he doesn't look like much at all
when his clones come out to play well
Gigi's my friends Gigi's truly deserving
of a higher place on this list and those
that can beat him are truly very special
indeed
one of which being maybe an interesting
choice for being this far up on the list
but it's the fan favorite flame hushra
kyojiro rengoku rengoku was an absolute
Powerhouse and a very special case in my
opinion rengoku was extremely skilled
and proficient when it came to his power
and fighting capabilities throughout the
series he has frequently exhibited his
remarkable swordsmanship Talon for me
rengoku was easily one of the strongest
and most talented Swordsmen in the whole
Demon Slayer corpse and very worthy of
the harshera title A further advantage
kyotro had is that he is a member of the
ren Goku family which boasts an
outstanding Heritage of strong Swordsmen
and Flame hushra not saying that he
didn't work hard to get where he did not
at all but my point is that it was in
his blood he was born with natural
talent and on top of his sword skills
was of course his flame breathing a
breathing style that kyojo was taught by
shinjiro rengoku the previous flame
harshera and of course his father
rengoku further learned through through
studying the text that the previous
flame harsh were left behind in the
rengoku family now kyotre was the most
accomplished flame breathing user of his
time we saw clearly just how develops
his combat skills with the breathing
style were when he took out the former
lower Rank 2 and during his fight with
upper ranked three akaza throughout his
battle with akaza the upper three
constantly praised rengoku's
swordsmanship which is a massive
compliment coming from a demon who has
killed countless harshera some believe
that rengoku may have won his fight with
akaza under different circumstances but
I'm not too sure akaza is no joke like I
honestly think that rengoku would have
been able to take out hontengu but in
ranking everyone it did make me think it
made me think man the question I raised
you is how strong do you think rengoku
would have been if he had awakened his
Demon Slayer Mark like I've placed him
this high on the list without him ever
manifesting it but how powerful would he
have become strong enough to have beaten
akaza strong enough to have become the
strongest harsher of his generation I
don't know but I'd honestly love to have
seen it I I think it would have been
incredible definitely let us know your
thoughts on this one in the comment
section below
above rangoku we have the missed hashra
moichiro mumichiro is another one of
those that doesn't really look like much
when we first meet him but we very
quickly find out that he is a true
Prodigy and his reputation is most
certainly well earned muchira is a child
prodigy and an extremely strong and
talented Warrior despite his youth he is
renowned for his incredible Talent he
became a hashra after only two months of
training something that was only
accomplished by one other kiome
murichiro is the most skilled Mist
breathing user of his time he was so
good at misbreathing that he invented a
completely new technique seventh form
obscuring clouds that was crucial in
helping him defeat upper rank 5 Kyoko
what I do love about murichiro is his
attention to detail did you know that
murichiro wears loose garments to better
disguise his movements from his
adversaries and to increase the
effectiveness of his breathing style now
much Hero's Talent is so great that even
upper rank 1 kokoshibo expressed his
admiration for his abilities with this
breathing Style by saying that it is
beyond his expectations where you know
is that as big that's pretty big praise
what's even more impressive when it
comes to murichiro and kokoshibo is that
muichiro is actually a descendant from
him and his brother yorichi who of
course is the strongest Demon Slayer
ever now a major increase in mitiro's
power was when he unlocked the Demon
Slayer Mark against Kyoko and increased
his power as a Demon Slayer even further
later on in the battle against kokoshibo
when he gained access to the transparent
world as well as turning his nitrine
sword red muchira is more than deserving
of such a higher place on the list and
it's even more impressive when you take
his age into account moochiro is just 14
years old that's just insane when you
think about it I can't even begin to
imagine what he would have been like in
another five or ten years time
moving on to the king of personality the
ever happy ever smiling water hushra
Kiyu tamioka guiyu is an exceptional
Talon and a real asset to the demon
slayer's cause even if he doesn't think
so himself gear has proven time and time
again just how powerful a fighter he is
be it easily dispatching demons that
have equal strength to a lower moon or
holding his own against upper Moon
through akaza which may I add he was
also given the same offer that akaza
gave rengoku in that akaza was so
impressed by his skills that he offered
to turn him into a demon rather than
killing him obviously an offer that he
isn't going to take him up on but that's
a huge compliment either way now for me
one of gyu's greatest strengths is in
his teamwork capabilities Kyu is able to
quickly work out his teammates movements
and intentions and then instantly adapt
himself to support them as we have seen
many a time in Demon Slayers some of
those demons are stupidly strong and the
only way to take them down is by working
together and combining each other's
strengths to gain the edge yes this list
is about strength and power individually
but it's Geo's talent to adapt to a
situation that I feel adds more to his
overall ability now talking of gui's
abilities as an individual let's look at
his water breathing Gio is the most
accomplished water breathing use of his
time a breathing style that the water
harshera who came before him rokadaki
taught him Geo has achieved perfect
Mastery of water breathing to the extent
that he invented a brand new breathing
form 11th form Dead Calm now on top of
his impressive skill as the water hushra
gear also awakened his Demon Slayer Mark
as well as managing to turn his nitrine
sword red and though our boy gained the
praise of upper Moon three akaza I don't
think he is beating him in a one-on-one
fight obviously he and Tandra managed to
just do the job but that was together
but made no mistake Q is one of the
strongest demon Slayers we have ever
seen
the third strongest harshera Goes To
None other than the wind harshera saname
this guy is an absolute Beast he is
often demonstrated his amazing skills
and battle prowess sonomi was able to
keep up with an impress upper rank 1
kakushibo a demon with centuries of
battle experience and this was all due
to his swordsmanship abilities and
skills as a Demon Slayer now an
interesting thing about tsunami is his
blood sonomi's blood is one of the
rarest blood kinds making demons want
and find it extremely alluring due to
its incredible potency even the
slightest sniff of it instantly causes
demons to salivate and lose
concentration sanami's blood was even
able to affect the strongest of the
upper ranks in kakashibo now sonomi is
regarded as the generation's most
accomplished wind breathing user
kakashibo was reminded of the first
windhashra from the sengoku era the
Golden Age of demon Slayers by his
degree of water breathing Prof say now
further enhancing his already incredible
power sonomi also awakened his Demon
Slayer Mark and managed to turn his knee
terrine sword red and it goes without
saying that tsunami was absolutely
incredible and a very strong Demon
Slayer the guy earned plenty of Praise
from upper Moon one kakashibo however he
also said in the battle against him that
sonomi's physical prowess and skill
level have peaked meaning that he was at
his best now you can't complain with
this level of power but it doesn't earn
you the top spot on this list which
means I don't think he could have soloed
any of the upper three moons though he
would certainly have given them a run
for their money
the second strongest hashra is the snake
hashra igoro abanai now forget the norm
when talking about this guy for a second
I just want to throw some stuff out
there to Showcase you all just how
impressive this dude really is so we
find out that igoro was pretty much
blind in one eye so this means that he
not only gained the rank of hashra but
also became one of the strongest harsher
of the corpses ever seen and all pretty
much with just one eye not only that but
this guy is definitely not the strongest
when it comes to the physical side of
things in an arm wrestling competition
between the hashra iguru is literally
second last just above shinobu so yeah
with one eye and a small and weak
physique igoro Rose to the very top and
I don't know if you need any motivation
for anything today but man is that a
success story If Ever I heard one or
maybe the uh the other harshera need to
step up the game so igoro created and
perfected the breathing technique known
as serpent breathing this breathing
style employs twists and turns to strike
in unusual ways much like a serpent
slither serpent breathing was further
improved by including his pet snake
cabaroma into it which is amazing I've
always been dead impressed with that it
kind of reminds me of Kiba in Azuka and
akamaru from Naruto now just like the
previous few hushra on the list igoro
also awakened his Demon Slayer Mark and
managed to turn his knee terrine sword
red which gave his powers and abilities
a major boost igoro for me is just so
very impressive and I really do love
what he has managed to achieve
throughout the series yes he's not
taking out any of the top three upper
moons on his own but he's certainly
going to give them a tough time
next up is the strongest hushra the
Demon Slayer corpse has ever seen in
none other than the stone harshera kyome
himeshima now if you think igoro was
impressive for Rising through the ranks
with pretty much one eye then prepare to
have your socks completely shredded my
friends as Gomez was blind this guy is
an absolute unit If Ever I did see one
like he stands at over seven foot and is
just built like an absolute Fortress I
mean his one hand alone could completely
Crush my head now my head is quite small
mind you but even if it was twice as big
he'd still crush it like it was nothing
now like we mentioned earlier our boy
geome earned his harshera title after
only two months which is absolutely
insane to lend even more support to how
amazingly strong yomei was kokoshibo
upper Moon one stays to himself the
kyoma's insane physical prowess had been
developed to its maximum Peak and was at
the Pinnacle of his power kakashiba
further claimed that he had not come
across a warrior of gum Calabar in the
past 300 years now to further
demonstrate his awesomeness girome
managed to briefly engage the toughest
upper rank in battle and this was all
without the aid of his Demon Slayer Mark
of course he awokened it a bit later but
there was a period where he didn't have
that and of course Demon Slayer Mark
being mentioned kyoma had it all you
know he awakened his Demon Slayer Mark
turned his nitrine blade red and despite
being blind also gained access to the
transparent World jiome utilizes a
spiked flail on Ax similar to a kasuri
gamma a weapon made of a scythe and a
heavy iron weight linked by a metal
chain this is in contrast of course to
the other demon Slayers who fight with
swords or katanas kirame uses Stone
breathing and in his own adaptation of
this breathing style he uses his spiked
flail and acts in combination with his
superhuman hearing and physical power it
goes without saying but kyome is the
most gifted Stone breathing user of his
generation in his fight with kakashimo
he demonstrated his Mastery of stone
Breathing by using it to unleash
assaults that could counter the Demon's
Moon breathing Jeremy is just on a whole
different level when it comes to the
harshera and it was I gotta admit it was
a struggle in placing him just below a
Kaza or you know just above him
ultimately we went with just below I
think that if these two would have had
to have fought each other it would have
easily been one of the best in the
entire series but I think akaza is just
edging gome here as akaza has the power
to regenerate his head if decapitated
well it's the whole regeneration thing
really akaza could keep regeneration his
wounds as much as he wanted though kiome
would have had to have Beast modeed
through his own injuries which you know
ultimately he can't keep taking damage
like a kazakhan however again this is a
fight that I would just love to have
seen
that being said we of course move on to
Opera Moon three akaza taking the third
spot on this list akaza is a completely
different being and a huge jump up in
the power scale from hontangu and nakame
who of course occupied the open Moon 4
ranking now I don't think we we're ever
gonna forgive this guy for what he did
to our boy Ren Goku but this Demon's
backstory is one of the most
heartbreaking things ever and he has
certainly earned a lot of respect from
many fans however we're not here to talk
about his backstory but his powers in
why he ranks so high up on this list
akaza's already excellent strength and
combat abilities from his time as an
exceptional martial artist as a human
are significantly improved when he
became a demon in addition to his
ability to regenerate that we talked
about earlier his Blood Demon R allows
him to launch assaults that resemble
shock waves he can also use his blood
demon art to identify his opponent's
bloodlust or ferocity in his last
technique which he calls blue silver
chaotic after low he rapidly sends out a
great number of shock waves giu
attempted to neutralize it while using
his water breathing 11th form Dead Calm
which is known for its incredible
defensive capabilities but he was unable
to and instead received a hundred
strikes practically all at once as a
result akaza was just absolutely amazing
when it came to just how strong he was
he wasn't stronger than Doma much to his
annoyance but I think in time he maybe
could have been a castle is really
powerful and honestly I don't know what
his cap is if he hadn't chosen to die a
dignified death he would have vanquished
Dance of the fire god Tundra and awoken
Demon Slayer Mark gear perhaps going on
maybe to conquer Doma as well does he
get to the level where I think he can
take out kakashibo personally I don't
think so but I honestly think he does
get close
the second strongest on this list is the
maniac and honestly one of the most
messed up demons none other than upper
Moon 2 Doma being the third strongest
demon in existence as well as the second
ranking member of the 12 kizuki like you
just know that domura is absolutely no
joke at all his fighting prowess
combined with his formidable Blood Demon
are in battle is powerful enough to
overwhelm and destroy the most powerful
of demon Slayers we saw he took out the
insect hushra shinobukocho without any
problem and we know that he took out the
form of flowerhoshra or Kane kocho too
I'm sure the list of harshera on doma's
kill count is unbelievable to think of
to further demonstrate doma's power is
that akaza who is ranked up a three
wouldn't have had a chance against him
in combat this was all according to
Domer of course but I wouldn't call him
out on that especially because we know
that Doma surpassed akaza in a shorter
amount of time as a demon demonstrating
the vast difference in power between the
two demons now the fact that Doma rarely
fights seriously and instead adopts a
casual and carefreed attitude even in
life or death situations against the
most powerful demon Slayers is further
evidence of his immense power Doma only
ever becomes totally serious when his
life is in the most serious of danger
and we never saw that until he faced off
against inosuke and Canal where the
lethal effects of Shinobi's poisons
started to take effect now doma's blood
demon art is an incredibly strong
cryokinesis he has the ability to create
ice and Frost from his own blood spawn
it wherever in his immediate area and
manipulate it as he pleases unleashing
very strong ice tactics the icy conjures
with his Blood Demon are is also
exceedingly deadly to those who breathe
it in killing the cells in the victim's
lungs and leaving them unable to breathe
he channels his eyes Powers using two
fans and he can make ice clones of
himself to fight for him his most
powerful attack is that he can sculpt a
huge ice butter-like statue that can
strike adversaries and producers lethal
cold air that can instantly freeze his
enemies it goes without saying that Doma
is more than worthy of not only the high
ranking here but also his title of upper
Moon too but there is of course still
one more above him on the list and I
wonder who that could be right
taking the top spot on this list is the
very obvious upper Moon one kakashibo
obvious because there is just none like
this guy he is levels apart from every
single person slash demon on this list
you see this guy is on the battlefield
I'm sorry I don't care how Brave you are
but just get out of there man ggs like
you stick around you ain't making it out
there unless you find yourselves amongst
a group of incredibly strong hashura and
kokoshiba himself is having a change of
heart maybe thinking something along the
lines of you know what kind of Horrid
monster have I become only then I'd say
stick around but still at a moderately
safe distance health and safety above
above all you know so yeah kokoshibo is
the brother of the strongest demons Lair
of all time yorichi and Pride's becoming
a demon kakashibo was already very
strong himself also Awakening his Demon
Slayer Mark now demon enhanced Moon
breathing is used by upper Moon one
kakashibo now it seems fitting that you
reach his son breathing which is the
strongest breed eating style would be
followed by his brother's Moon breathing
as the second strongest form of
breathing so what really takes kakashiba
to another level is when you combine
Blood Demon techniques with it it gets
much deadlier just like we saw with
kaigaku and kakashiba had years of
experience behind him and of course a
much much stronger breathing style now
kakashimo's sword is surrounded by
several blades that resemble Crescent
moons and vary in size and length for
each cut it makes this makes his already
livable strikes even more powerful
broader and unpredictable his blade also
has numerous eyes on it too and these
eyes help him see further the saw can
regenerate when broken and change shape
and length because it is all composed of
his own flesh kokoshibo can send
Crescent blades in all directions from
anywhere on his body and these blades
effortlessly pierced through the skin of
his opponents to make things even worse
in facing kokoshibo even if you managed
somehow sever his head kokoshibo can
regrow it just like muzongan this guy
really is something else and there is no
question that he is the strongest on
this list in a one-on-one honestly no
one even holds a candle to him yes some
could hold their own against him but
their fate would ultimately be the same
and that is it every hoshra and Demon
Moon ranked from weakest to strongest we
certainly hope that you enjoyed this
ranking as it really was a lot of fun to
make definitely make sure to let us know
if you agreed with our ranking but also
let us know what fights you would have
loved to have seen in the series for me
it's definitely the kiome and akaza
fight that would have been amazing now
if you enjoyed this video and you'd like
to see more Demon Slayer videos on the
channel make sure to let us know by
Smashing that like button if you haven't
already make this the video you
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
to turn on all notifications or you will
miss future anime abroad videos remember
you can also follow us on Twitter and
Instagram at anime uproll thanks again
and we can't wait to see you in the next
one till next time